now everything's black and white
and you really have to be comfortable
with that gray area and that ambiguity
working for something that's already
created is way different than creating
something yourself
if you're an entrepreneur there's no
path that's laid out for you so you have
to be comfortable walking into that
darkness
and knowing that you're going to come
out on the other side ryan and i started
apl on the foundation that we created
the world's best
basketball technology the concept of
being the first to do something for me
is really
exciting so he created the first
technology that instantly makes you jump
higher october 19 2010
our shoes got banned by the nba we said
we can either fight this or we can
embrace this
let's keep going with this and see how
far we can take it it was the best thing
that ever happened for us
this one moment changed the trajectory
of our lives if you see a great
opportunity
and you feel that you can personally
maximize it you need to take it because
you never know when the next one's
coming from an innovation standpoint
we're able to look at something from a
different angle
nordstrom was the first account we
really opened up that has
over 100 stores and is in pretty much
every state
we expect a lot of the people to work
for us but at the same time
we want it to be more than just work we
want it to be fun as well whether it's
playing darts
on the mini basketball hoop ping pong we
have a creative environment in our
office
the only way to get further is to get
out of your comfort zone
it's consistent hard work every single
day
adam and i are usually up until about
three or four a.m every day we're
dealing with from all different places
from london
to paris to new york a lot of the huge
opportunities that we've got
have come from saying why not us